a celebration at the white house on
tuesday as u.s president joe biden
signed into law the inflation reduction
act
it's not just about today it's about
tomorrow it's about delivering progress
and prosperity to american families the
law cuts medicine costs for seniors and
extends health care subsidies there's
also a new 15 percent corporate income
tax the biggest expense fighting climate
change
385 billion dollars in new funding and
tax credits to cut carbon emissions and
develop clean energy industries
to expand the use of solar panels and
heat pumps and to make electric vehicles
a common sight the electric vehicle
provisions in the new bill are
are
phase in based on income
and so they are really designed to make
electric vehicles more affordable for
people who might not otherwise be able
to buy them west virginia senator joe
manchin had held up passage of the law
until it included funding for the oil
and gas industry he said he would do it
again and i think this is a great
american bill now someone benefits from
it that's why i can't figure out why my
republican friends are doubling down
against them when there's so much good
for so many people it's going to help so
many people it doesn't make any sense to
me at all and the bill as amended is
passed
republicans who didn't vote for the bill
criticized it on social media quote
democrats robbed americans last year by
spending our economy into record
inflation
this year their solution is to do it a
second time
back at the white house joe biden
delivered some of his own partisan
criticism
every single republican congress voted
against lowering prescription drug
prices against lowering health care
costs against the fairer tax system
every single republican every single one
voted against tackling the climate
crisis against lowering our energy costs
against creating good paying jobs
a recognition partisanship isn't over
even though the white house says this is
a day for all americans rosalyn jordan
al jazeera washington